folks I'm Hans scotson and with playoffs
approaching anxiety around the league is
at an all-time high this is NFL dread
Zone we begin in Philadelphia where
everyone is freaking the out to be good
or not to be good that is the uh
line it's the same place every week you
know you can always handle the bright
lights ncky fools yeah yeah yeah for
sure just got a dread alert from
Jacksonville where the Jags are stuck in
neutral am I the only reason were this
good or am I the reason we're not good
enough I asked if Pepsi was okay so um
do you uh want to go all the way don't
be silly we have to stop at the NFC
championship game like always I worry
that this might be my last shot at
greatness you know everybody always ask
how about them Cowboys no never ask how
are those cowboys you know oh sorry I
think that's our time oh and welcome to
the bitching hour where nerves get
preserved and groans become moans let's
start with a quad box in KC man I can't
anything just it in it's right there
this s SP seems like a lot of
frustration for a man who unlike me can
pee whenever he wants okay remember this
year you don't want to take the early
exit I know what's this guy's deal it's
old Joe still got a little gas in my
tank let's go to a hexa box of all the
fan bases who think they're cursed in
the playoffs they let me down every year
a the other fan bases think they know
[Music]
pain and it wouldn't be the dread Zone
without a stop in Miami oh God I thought
we had this all locked
up hi we're
back